Ron has formally invited the NTSB to
send their representatives to the crash
site the NTSB says it will not speculate
on the cause of this crash
transportation correspondent that's Kris
Van Cleave there he is is following the
investigation of the crash so Chris good
morning to you if this happened the way
that officials say that it did what went
terribly wrong here
oh good morning it appears this was a
horrific mistake at a time when tensions
were running very high in the Iranian
military was on high alert but certainly
there are questions take a look at this
this is from flightradar24 it's a flight
tracking web site here in the US notice
it
observed nine other flights leaving the
airport that morning before the
shoot-down nearly all of them following
the same path as flight 752 a security
camera captured these dramatic images of
the burning wreckage from Ukraine
International Airlines flight 752
raining down the plane headed to Kiev
was identifying itself as a commercial
airliner and was flying away from the
conflict zone but CBS News has learned
as the Boeing 737 climbed after takeoff
from Tehran's Airport Wednesday morning
US intelligence picked up signals of
Iranian radar locking onto the plane US
satellites detected two surface-to-air
missiles being launched followed by an
explosion this new video shows the
moment of impact other videos show the
burning plane as it comes crashing down
in a ball of fire federal officials
briefed on the Intel say pieces of the
missiles like these posted to social
media appeared to have been found near
the crash scene President Trump as the
news broke it was flying in a pretty
rough neighborhood and somebody could
have made a mistake sources say the
president worried about this exact
scenario specifically asking about
passenger planes flying over Iran in the
days leading up to the shoot down
there's no absolute precision when
things start happening in combat retired
naval captain Lawrence Brennan worked on
a similar investigation in 1988 after a
u.s. naval warship mistakenly shot down
in Iran Air flight killing 290 they're
going to be hostilities near commercial
aircraft there have to be warnings and
aircrafts have to be compelled to avoid
danger zone
about 30 minutes earlier another
commercial flight this one heading for
Hong Kong took off without incident now
experts we've talked to tell us the
radar operator who lit up flight 752
should have been able to see that it
originated from the airport and at that
point common sense should have taken
over Tony a brutal and terrifying error
if in fact that is what it is Kris thank
you very much
you